they plan Allah plans and Allah is the
best of planner so there's things that
are happening that we just um we don't
see the whole picture we just see a part
of it so I'm going to get you guys
reaction to uh to this 100% feel
comfortable saying that what's happening
now is the Palestinian people is another
Holocaust and they're still saying
alhamdulillah not yet alhamdulillah alul
Muslim Palestinians still seeing them
say Allah is all
knowing
Palestinians are doing everything that
was described job doing in the
Bible I've not seen any footage of
Palestinian people cursing Jewish people
or Israeli people these are people of
God I know these people were blessed by
Allah himself hold faith is is such an
indominable hope they don't give up
about this life okay the only thing
these people fear is
Allah that's it if this is the campaign
to to get Nations to be Islamic it's
doing it I've been shocked to my core at
the faith Muslim people have what is
happening in Palestine has opened my
eyes to the beauty of Islam that's
something that people don't get to see
often definitely not here in the west
into the Bible asking logical questions
were not allowed when I read through the
Quran I see logic and Divinity brought
together result of that is on social
media I have seen so many
people picking up the Quran and reading
it through you know this entire thing
with Palestine so many more people are
learning about Islam so many more people
are reading the Quran you got to have a
lot of people turning to Islam soon it's
happening again it's like all these
people I see Quan book club I see people
deciding to convert to Islam because
they're like well what what is really
going on here I just bought my first
copy of the Quran I got the Quran I
started reading the Quran it's my day
two in reading the Quran I got see how
these
pal literally are thanking God seeing
the
brave Palestine people as they're losing
everything so much faith and peace while
their families are being murdered States
we need a lot more empathy and
understanding of Muslims in the Arab
world I need to know what y'all foot in
Islam okay I just from reading the
second Surah I'm like I get it I
understand why there's such a steadfast
Faith to anyone that follows Islam being
shown just how wrong we were about this
faith and how rich how like how deep and
just the language of it oh how fluid and
beautiful it is we' been lied to the
Western people and I took my shahada I
feel tremendous peace I'm going to be
reading it forever Subhan Allah um these
people right now are acting as as as the
pillars you know in the Muslim Community
may Allah have mercy on them grant them
the highest levels of Jenna and continue
to make them an inspiration for us um
something that
umman mentioned on podcast that we did
with him was uh something that was sent
to him and I'm going to paraphrase a bit
along the lines of that you know
basically they have the right upon us or
for us uh to be happy to see us you know
thriving and all that stuff and and they
have we also have a right towards them
that we don't forget about them you know
in in in our joy in our good times that
you know we have to speak out for them
and
hamdulillah they have been like
tremendous like people think that we're
doing something for them you know I I
swear they're doing way more for us they
they I swear they're doing so much more
for me than I could ever do for them may
Allah have mercy on them and bless them
and um I have seen a lot of people on
Tik Tok just you know just scrolling
through I see people doing live Quran
sessions and reading the Quran more all
because these amazing men and women are
leading by example that is deep yeah you
know how many non-muslims when
westerners looked into Islam after 911 I
think it's a it's a cast effect and the
master following as always says you know
he led the in the St Louis mjid and he
was saying that all this did was just
expose everyone's true intention you
know to the masses because they're going
and looking to see what does the Quran
say exactly smart person be like okay
let's see what's the Quran say for
myself they know the media lies and
they're like wow they're just blown away
and they start like talking about you
know how the Quran is beautiful how how
was this how was that and you seen I
mean you recently not too long ago also
had a similar experience right what was
uh we had your story you're someone who
came to Islam how long's it been now
three four years two years it's been a
little over three years three years
around three years yeah a little over
three years can you relate also
like yeah I can it's it's very beautiful
to see somethingone like that especially
when the woman says
that these people speaking about the
Palestinians that they don't care about
this life they just care about Allah
yeah you heard that huh and like I hear
that bro
and it it makes me look at my own life
and like how I make mistakes
and it's deep man I mean you see like B
bombs are falling falling on them and
we're over here complaining about this
that and the other and it's it's a shame
may Allah forgive us mean a
meano may Allah keep our hearts alive I
feel it man this is amazing and you see
like how how they're talking about um
the woman's like the woman's like she's
not even uh they're not even cursing I
don't hear him even cursing uh Jews I
don't did you hear her say that yeah I
haven't heard one video cursing most of
them are saying La say say God is one
say there's nothing worthy of worship
but God the kala right you see them
saying that means there's nothing where
they worship but God and um and then
they go back and some of them are even
accepting Islam and why the question for
for anybody why would you if the
mainstream media is telling you these
are um sympathizers to a barbaric way of
life and their animals this day and
other but then the smart people they're
going and investigating and here's the
reactions we got right here here's the
reactions and these are just the people
these are note these are just the people
that came out how many people are camera
shy don't operate with you know Tik Tock
or any of these how many of them are
there huh I'll never forget bro it's I
think this was something that she Omar
was saying that if if you have a problem
with Islam and Islam doesn't make sense
to you then you're going to convince
yourself that Islam doesn't make sense
period and that it doesn't make sense to
anybody but it's it has nothing to do
with Islam has everything to do with you
you have a personal obligation not even
as you know a Muslim or a non-muslim but
just as a human being to just wake up
and do your damn research like it
shouldn't be that difficult everybody
has that personal obligation to do that
because we live in a world today where
truth is quite literally being portrayed
as falsehood and falsehood is being you
know shoved down our throats as truth
and I believe that as a man as a woman
as a Muslim as a non-muslim
we're all going to die it's guaranteed
and Allah says in the Quran that on that
day even Shan the Devil Himself he's not
going to co-sign for our mistakes he's
not going to take any accountability we
can't diffuse anything and be a victim
on that day and even blame the Devil
Himself so I don't understand why people
can't just wake up and and re and again
at the end of the day that's why Allah
says in the Quran like it's not up to
you oh Prophet Allah guides who he Wills
you know you can just give them the
message you can take them to the water
you can't make them drink so it's
unfortunate but it warms my heart you
know seeing all these brothers and
sisters in that Tik Tok compilation that
you showed us right now Eddie that
there's still so many sincere people
withas like they want it they want the
truth and I'm sure you know back in the
jahia all of us we can relate to this
that there's a turning point where we
just wanted the truth and once it clicks
it clicks once you hit that five out of
five you know in your Salah you don't go
back M it's just clear-headed you know
you know and I pray that Allah can give
that to everyone and anybody watching
you know the only thing that I can
recommend you is to read the Quran you
know if you don't know Arabic obviously
get the clear Quran or an English
translation that you Rec you know that
you prefer and just start with that you
know this is what happened with brother
an over here who's a revert with myself
and Ramy were born Muslims but we came
on to it of our own you know volition
later in our life yeah I was just going
to say man and forgive me I I don't I
don't usually C so no know I felt I felt
it I feel you man when I when I first
saw that it was uh you
know mean me to bless you I mean it's
just crazy to see because you have the
verse in the Quran where Allah says that
indeed they
plan but indeed Allah plans and Allah
plans is greater yes
and something that I
learned a long time ago is that the only
way that we as humans we can connect the
dots is by looking back looking at
what's already happened and the only
person that can connect the dots looking
forward is
Allah and when we hear this Ayah in the
Quran like we understand it yes but now
we're seeing it and we're seeing these
people what they're going through and
what Ramy said how they're doing more
for us than we're doing for them you
know like what they're going through the
da that they're giving to all the these
people that are not Muslims what they're
making actual Muslims realize and just
wake up and move away from this dun from
this life and get back closer to Allah
like it's just to me that that's it's a
very very beautiful thing to see like
again like my heart really goes out to
these
people and anyone in the right state of
mind would want this to stop right